the creatures of the deep are hard to fathom
that's because collecting them takes equipment like nets and suction tubes
which can injure the delicate animals.
now scientists have come up with a kinder gentler way of handling these creatures
inspired by the mechanisms that move kids toys
and even our own hands.
researchers from the Wyss Institute at Harvard University invented a prototype gentle mechanical hand
that can safely capture deep-sea creatures.
the device is composed of two-dimensional shapes that fold to create a three-dimensional enclosure.
think of it like origami where a single piece of paper can be shaped into a crane or a ball
only in this case the shapes and folds are predicted mathematically.
the prototype had five main panels that are comprised of two smaller panels
all the panels are connected to a central link that's controlled by a rotary actuator.
this coordinates the panels so they can be folded together at the same time
like closing fingers into a fist.
and similar to our hands this device is also attached to an arm
which can be mounted on an underwater vehicle and controlled remotely
the grabber can dive deep while scientists watch safely from their ship.
not only is it safe for the researchers
but it's safe for sea creatures as well
that's because of the soft silicon edges of the panels.
the scientists can stop the cage from closing at any time as they can watch its progress by video
future versions of the device might include sensors that can measure an organism's vitals
or a 3D scanner that can reveal how their bodies act differently at these depths
compared to the low-pressure surface.
given its simple design,
the “mechanical hand” might one day be kitted up for work in outer space
perhaps as a way of manipulating solar panels to power satellites
but for now, this device is already “lending a hand” to deep-sea research